[Musique]
je
proclamation unilatérale des états unis
du retour des sanctions de l'onu contre
l'iran la nuit dernière par la voix de
son secrétaire d'état à washington
menace de sanctions duc secondaire tous
ceux qui violeraient ce dispositif
punitif il n'a aucune légitimité
juridique
le reste du monde
tout premier scrutin organisé depuis le
début de la pandémie en italie des
élections régionales pour désigner les
présidents de cette région
la droite pour être remporté la moitié
des italiens qui votent aussi par
référendum pour réduire le nombre de
leurs députés
c'était une promesse du
cinq étoiles au pouvoir avec le parti
démocrate
[Musique]
nouvelles manifestations contre le
pouvoir en biélorussie depuis un mois et
demi les protestataires réclament le
départ du président loukachenko
demain la leader de l'opposition qui
revendique la victoire lors de
l'élection du 9 août sera reçu par les
ministres des affaires
étrangère européenne
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche cette
déclaration la nuit dernière du chef de
la diplomatie américaine mike pompéo a
annoncé le rétablissement unilatérale
d'anciennes sanctions de l'onu contre
l'iran alors que les etats-unis ont
quitté l'accord de vienne l'iran appelle
le monde je cite à parler d'une seule
voix contre les actions qualifiées
d'irresponsables des américains et la
medjahed dans un communiqué surprise
mike pompéo salue le retour de quasiment
toutes les sanctions de l'onu contre
téhéran
auparavant levé washington qui par la
voix de son secrétaire d'état
lance une menace à peine voilée aux
autres pays des nations du nord
si des états membres de l'onu ne
remplissent pas leurs obligations pour
appliquer ces sanctions les etats-unis
sont prêts à utiliser leurs propres
outils pour punir ces défaillances
nike pompéo promet l'annnonce de mesure
ces prochains jours contre ceux qui
violent les sanctions de l'onu
et c'est le président donald trump qui
pourrait dévoiler une sorte de système
punitif dit secondaire
les contrevenants désigné par washington
ce ver est par exemple bloqué d'accès au
marché au système financier américain
une annonce qui devrait être fait lors
du discours mardi prochain du locataire
de la maison blanche à l'occasion de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
mais voilà dans le dossier iranien les
états unis sont seuls contre tous ou
presque sur la scène internationale les
autres grandes puissances onusienne
comme la chine et la russie rejette ce
train de sanctions les initiatives et
actions il légitime des états unis ne
peuvent par définition avoir de
conséquences internationales légale pour
les autres pays
l'attitude de washington a porté un
grand coup à l'autorité du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu et a montré
ouvertement du mépris pour ces décisions
et pour la législation internationale
dans son ensemble
les alliés de washington sur le vieux
continent signataires de l'accord de
2015 sur le programme nucléaire iranien
ont eu eux adressé une lettre commune au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu toute
décision ou mesure prise dans
l'intention de rétablir les sanctions
n'aura aucun effet juridique l'iran
appelle de son côté le mot
à parler d'une seule voix face aux états
unis la communauté internationale doit
décider seul de ce qu'elle doit faire
contre ces brimades non voulue par le
pape
malheureusement en raison de l'
influence des etats unis sur les marchés
financiers tous pour être appliqué ces
sanctions financières et bien sûr ce
qu'ils appliquent 10 nous le faisons
même si nous savons qu'elles sont
illégales car les états unis sont
puissants et feront pression la
communauté internationale n'a pas
remarqué que les mêmes principes
fonctionneront contre eux aussi cela
signifie que les états unis auront la
même approche envers le nord stream par
exemple qu'ils feront de même avec deux
troupes projet puisque un tyran continue
toujours l'intimidation
si vous le laissez faire une seule fois
et c'est le conseil que le monde
commence à comprendre
il y à un mois le conseil de sécurité
avait rejeté une résolution des états
unis contre l'iran en réaction les
américains avaient prévenu qu'ils
passeraient en force en utilisant le
mécanisme du snav bac
ce mécanisme permet à tout état
signataire de force et unilatéralement
le nu à rétablir l'ensemble des
sanctions imposées à téhéran avant
l'accord de 2015 sur le nucléaire
iranien
un argument qui ne tient pas pour les
autres pays membres des nations unies et
les estiment que washington n'a plus le
droit d'utiliser ce mécanisme puisque
les états unis ont quitté cet accord à
l'arrivée de donald trump à la maison
blanche
une déclaration qui a provoqué un tollé
international pour l'union européenne
cette manoeuvre n'a aucun fondement
juridique la russie elle a démenti cette
reprise de ces sanctions
elle a appelé les états unis à ne pas
s'exprimer au nom des nations unies il
est très douloureux de voir un grand
pays s'humilier ainsi et s'opposer dans
son délire obstinée aux autres membres
du conseil de sécurité de l'onu nous
avions tous clairement dit en août que
cette manoeuvre était illégitime et ce
que washington est sourd des iraniens
pris en otage on entre le jeu des
grandes puissances c'est ce que déplore
un manager rallye elle est enseignante à
sciences po et auteur des mystères de
l'iran contemporain les américains
temps posé lors hégémonie sur la planète
et il y à des pays il y à des puissances
qui résistent comme la chine comme la
russie et comme les européens et
malheureusement pour les iraniens
malheureusement pour le peuple iranien
qui sont pris en otage entre deux corps
de groupes de puissance d'un côté les
américains donc d'autres côté les autres
personnes personne ne fait attention aux
intérêts du peuple iranien
personne ne demande la vie du papier
ralliant les iraniens sont un peuple
paisible
ils ne veulent la guerre avec personne
avec aucun pays et ils ne comprennent
pas pourquoi depuis 42 ans
leurs dirigeants sont systématiquement
en situation conflictuelle avec les
puissances du monde à commencer par les
américains et les espagnols ils ne
comprennent pas un accord in extremis
entre les patrons de l'application
chinoise tik tok et les états unis la
nuit dernière donald trump qui avait
menacé de ne plus pouvoir continuer à
utiliser l'application accusée
d'espionnage par la maison blanche
mais un accord a donc été trouvé à la
dernière minute la maison-mère de tik
tok a proposé à l'entreprise oracle
d'être son partenaire technologique
privilégié et à wal mart autres entités
américaines d'être son partenaire
commercial aux états unis les deux
sociétés américaines qui pourront
acquérir jusqu'à 20% du capital de tik
tok globale avant une éventuelle entrée
en bourse est ce qui semble quelque peu
avoir assuré le président américain a
écouté le je pense que c'est une bonne
chose et une bonne affaire pour la
mairie compte embaucher au moins
vingt-cinq mille personnes elle sera
très probablement incorporé au texas
toute nouvelle société
elle n'aura rien à voir avec un pays
étranger elle n'aurait rien à voir avec
la chine sera totalement sécurisée cela
fera partie de la corée et ce sera à la
fois oracle comme vous le savez et valu
mart et je pense que ce sera un accord
fantastique et voyez ce qu'on dit pedro
zwan s neto il est responsable numérique
du mouvement république souveraine
il faut savoir que tik tok
ni moins la version utilisée par
l'occident et à la base on va dire une
société américaine qui était musical y
est donc
jusqu'à maintenant les chinois
effectivement avait investi énormément
dans l'achat de cette entreprise mais le
coeur opérationnelle de l'entreprise a
toujours été aux états unis
effectivement y'a rien on va dire est
tous les spécialistes de la technologie
avait rien qui pouvait attester une
quelconque surveillance réel des réseaux
via tik tok surtout que dans les faits
on peut se poser la question si des
adolescentes de 12 ans qui dansent en
croupe top représente un réel risque
pour la sécurité des états unis
dans tous les cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que pour contre up c'est une victoire il
montre qui fait plier la chine son grand
ennemi que il arrive à créer une
multitude d'emplois aux états unis ce
qui reste quand même à prouver parce que
25000 emplois surtout dans un secteur de
technologie c'est pas rien est ce que je
sache
ti knock dépasse d'une entreprise qui
génère autant de revenus
ça génère des revenus mais surtout la
plupart de ces revenus sont générés par
les différentes levée de fonds donc pas
forcément par son chiffre d'affaires
mais effectivement pour lui ça va
permettre dans le cadre de la campagne
électorale de pouvoir dire regardez j'ai
fait piller chinois j'ai obtenu des
emplois pour les américains
c'était une victoire assez facile mais
sur lequel je pense qu'il va vouloir
capitaliser un maximum se tiennent
dimanche de contestation en biélorussie
plusieurs milliers de militants dans les
rues de minsk à nouveau contre la
élection d'alexandre loukachenko à la
marche des familles r415 personnes ont
été arrêtées pour participation à une
manifestation interdite
plus des trois quarts ont été libérés ce
matin selon le ministère de l'intérieur
l'opposante en exil soufflaient que la
nati canopes sky à l appel à l'onu à
agir elle sera reçu demain par les
ministres des affaires étrangères
européens et nam medjahed et grâce
d'ailleurs c'est par le biais d'un
message vidéo que svetlana chicanos sky
a interpellé ce vendredi le conseil des
droits de l'homme des nations unies la
situation en biélorussie exige une
attention immédiate de la part de la
communauté internationale des
manifestants pacifiques sont
illégalement détenus frappée et violée
nous la majorité démocratique de
biélorussie nous avons à plusieurs
reprises exprimé notre attachement à
l'état de droit aux valeurs
démocratiques et au dialogue pacifique
la requête de l'opposante en exil en
lituanie a été en partie entendue par
l'onu le projet d'un rapport sur la
situation en biélorussie a été votée à
genève une intervention de svetlana
chicanos callas très critiquée par les
représentants russes et des le russe aux
nations unies elle est contraire selon
eux au règlement du conseil des droits
de l'homme qui tu finis moigne je
voudrais attirer votre attention et
l'attention de toutes les personnes
présentes ici brad cats auraient sur le
fait que le format des débats urgents
qui se déroule aujourd'hui ne prévoit
pas la participation des noms
représentant du haut commissariat des
nations unies aux droits de l'homme
cher au commissaire adjoint des nations
unies aux droits de l'homme ni du
rapporteur spécial ni de personne
d'autre
sauf les états chrome est presque aucune
manifestation ne s'est déroulé
conformément à la loi sur l'organisation
de rassemblements de masse en
l'occurrence nous ne parlons pas de
l'interdiction du droit de manifester
pacifiquement mais de la procédure de sa
mise en oeuvre
les participants violer la loi par
conséquent il ya eu des milliers
d'arrestations
en dépit des déclarations des opposants
au gouvernement
les manifestations de la période du
au 12 août n'était pas toujours
pacifiques et les mieux renaître hâte
d'être là nachi canucks callas ne compte
pas en rester là puisqu'elle est attendu
lundi à bruxelles pour rencontrer les
ministres européens des affaires
étrangères lieu qui multiplie les
condamnations travail à une liste de
sanctions contre alexandre loukachenko
et refuse de reconnaître sa réélection
du 9 août dernier
de son côté le président de la
biélorussie a annoncé ce jeudi la
fermeture des frontières avec certains
pays voisin mais paul et moi même je
tends vous et quand le cheval aspects
sociaux mais comprenons qu'il ne leur
reste plus beaucoup de possibilités dans
leur arsenal en dehors du lancement
d'une guerre chaude athlétique nous
sommes donc obligés de retirer les
troupes des rues et de les déplacer de
mettre l'armée en état d'alerté de
fermer la frontière du pays à l'ouest
principalement avec la lituanie et la
pologne
nous sommes obligés de renforcer notre
frontière renforcé la frontière avec
notamment ces exercices militaires
menées vendredi dans la région de brest
près de la frontière avec la pologne
des manoeuvres conjointes de misc et de
moscou le kremlin qui a réitéré ces
derniers jours son soutien à alexandre
loukachenko et condamné toute forme
d'ingérence tout premier scrutin
organisé depuis le début de la pandémie
en italie des élections régionales pour
désigner les présidents de cette région
la droite qui pourrait d'ailleurs
remporté la moitié des italiens qui
votent aussi pour le par référendum pour
réduire le nombre de leurs députés
c'était une promesse du mouvement 5
étoiles le mouvement qui est au pouvoir
avec le parti démocrate dans une
coalition des italiens peu mobilisé en
tout cas à la mi-journée avec un une
participation de 12 3% écoutez les
nous pouvons réduire les gens que je
n'aime pas parce que je pense qu'ils
gagnent trop j'aurais réduit la moitié
des salaires plutôt que le nombre de
parlementaires de toute façon toutes
formes d'épargné de l'état est toujours
money tout doit changer pour que les
choses s'améliorent en ce moment
l'italie est en train de couler les
politiciens le savent mais ne regarde
pas l'avenir
il regarde seulement leur siège ce n'est
pas correct de réduire de cette façon
nous devons réduire en donnant au peuple
le droit de s'exprimer
il faut mais qu'il s'agit d'une réforme
générale des institutions
cependant nous sommes habitués aux
promesses du gouvernement qui ne sont
pas mises en oeuvre si ce référendum
était une fin en soi il ne serait pas
utile ce dont nous avons vraiment besoin
c'est d'une modification de la
constitution
une italie qui a donc besoin de réformes
portées par le mouvement 5 étoiles
voyait l'analyse de sirop perelli il est
avocat au barreau de milan moment king
ouest il il vend à consolider sa
position politique par rapport à la
lutte contre la caste et les privilèges
c'est à dire c'est une bonne démarche du
pouvoir aller vers le comme on dit une
économie du solide mais ne constitue qu
est un good à l'océan l'italie et la
belgique
des réformes sur le plan du droit social
et la besoin d les formes
sur le plan des infrastructures disons
qu'ils le coût des réductions par
rapport au gaumont dire au salève débat
la main tel père a présenté le début le
début d'une lutte qui n'est pas
seulement contre la casse mais d'une
lutte qui est l'objet des oies donner à
l'économie italienne une comme on dit
les brise comme on le souhaite pas toute
valeur
un point sur l'épidémie de coronavirus
en france avec ces nouveaux chiffres ce
soir plus de dix mille 500 nouveaux cas
détectés ces dernières 24 heures un taux
de positivité qui augmente légèrement à
5 7% toujours 89 départements
répertoriés en situation de
vulnérabilité modérée ou élevée
douze morts de plus que ce qui hier ce
qui porte le bilan des décès à plus de
31 mille cinq cents ces sept derniers
jours près d'autres 3900 personnes ont
été hospitalisées loi là pour les
chiffres et pour en parler nous sommes
avec florian philippot président des
patriotes et conseiller régional du
grand est auteur de comics 19
l'oligarchie démasqué publié par amazon
bonsoir florian philippot merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors vous avez
écrit ce livre pour dee doo ne plus
vivre cela le fiasco européen sur la
santé les mensonges du gouvernement le
scandale des ehpad où la sphère de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine qu'elles le sont
selon vous doit-on en tirer mais je
crois qu'on peut déjà en tirer les
leçons mais malheureusement mais encore
on vit encore en absurdie si vous voulez
on doit on a bien vu tous les français
ont vu les mensonges du début de
l'épidémie quand canton en france on a
été un des seuls pays à ne pas fermer
nos frontières par exemple ce qui est
hallucinant et en fait on ne l'a jamais
fait pendant la crise c'est
incompréhensible
on a on est tout de suite tombé sur raul
quand il a proposé un traitement
on a on a dit d'abord que les masques ne
servait à rien j'en avais pas pour les
soignants ce qui est un véritable
scandale et maintenant on nous dit
exactement inverse qu'il faut en mettre
partout pour tout le monde obligatoire
que c'est la panacée
il nous parle même plus de ce qui est
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire d'abord se
laver les mains
mais il ya quelque chose qui cloche dans
cette affaire depuis le début ça a été
très mal gérée l'union européenne
effectivement un rôle des lecteurs parce
qu'elle ouvre grand nos frontières a
détruit notre système de santé par
l'austérité à désindustrialise
grandement la france et on l'a payé très
cher ne met rien n'est réglé et pour le
moment on s'enfonce en absurdie par des
décisions de plus en plus déconnectés de
la réalité sanitaire et et qui moi me
font peur je ne sais pas dans quelle
société on nous prépare demain en tout
cas je pense qu'on aura
à plus de sécurité sanitaire et surtout
va y perdre en terme de liberté et de
prospérité
alors vous dressez évidemment le constat
de tous les dysfonctionnements qu'il y a
eu pendant pendant le confinement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous trouvez que le
gouvernement en a tiré les conséquences
on voit la politique des tests qui est
quand même un peu hasardeuse une
politique de confinement par quartier
une politique en tout cas à géométrie
variable les français sont un peu perdus
aujourd'hui qu'en pensez vous ah mais je
pense qu'on continue dans le grand
cirque s'ils voulaient la politique de
test est très symptomatique vous avez
raison d'abord il ya pas de casque quand
il fallait qu'il en est en mars avril et
quasiment pas de test alors qu'il
fallait qu'il en ait beaucoup il y avait
à l'époque
huit cent mille morts par jour je le
rappelle un maintenant c'est profusion
de tests tous remboursés d'ailleurs par
la sécurité sociale moi je pense qu'au
bout plus ciblées il faut cibler pour
avoir des résultats en moins de 24
heures est idéalement même en moins de
12 heures mais en ciblant et en
remboursant uniquement ceux qui auront
une prescription médicale
ce qui permettra d'alléger soul et les
files d'attenté puis ça rendra plus
efficace beaucoup plus efficace les
choses
c'est incroyable c'est que cette
affaire-là c'est comme les masques et
ils veulent un peu exorciser on dirait
leur cachet original il n'y avait pas de
masquer pas de test alors aujourd'hui
nouvelles des tests et des masques
partout mais franchement le
manifestement c'est que ça fonctionne
pas c'est pas la bonne solution
au final on ferait mieux de regarder par
exemple les suédois et suédois la veille
à un épidémiologiste très compétents de
ces länder sternhell et qui dit il faut
faire autrement
nous on croit pas aux masses obligatoire
à l'extérieur on pense qu'il ya même un
risque de contamination si vous
l'utilisez mal si vous utilisez pour le
même masque dans le comtat évident parce
que vous avez mis vos mains partout et
que vous savez pas comment le bien le
maître vous ne changez pas toutes les
trois heures comme il faut et ai eu
ensuite à vue puis fin juin ils ont des
résultats bien meilleurs chez nous on va
plus en plus à la restriction des
libertés la restriction de la vie
culturelle démocrate hier en tout cas de
l'offre se rapprochent de ceux de la
france ils sont pas forcément bien
meilleure mais en tout cas ils sont
quasiment similaires
c'est à dire coût global et finissent
par être similaires parce qu'au début
ils ont un excès de mortalité importante
dans les ehpad ils ont mal géré il faut
le dire les quinze premiers jours très
mal gérée dans leur maison de retraite
après ils ont corrigé mais depuis fin
juin ils sont très largement 2
nous et surtout ils détruisent beaucoup
moins leur vie économique leur vie
sociale leur vie scolaire leur vie
culturelle leur vie démocratique en
france
je sais pas quel monde on nous prépare
mais il n'est pas il n'est pas joyeux et
et surtout il et on va vers des
restrictions considérables de nos
libertés n'est remise en cause
incroyable jamais vu de l'état de droit
et ça devrait faire débat or ça ne fait
pas débat il ya une espèce de consensus
parmi les autorités en tout cas qui moi
m'interpelle et me fait peur parlant des
chiffres qui sont donnés tous les soirs
chez une sur rt france également de
façon très factuelle 26 morts hier 12
aujourd'hui on peut pas parler d'une
deuxième vague concrètement non bien sûr
que non mais vous avez beaucoup de
médecins en épidémiologie ce qu'ils
disent depuis le début on peut pas
parler d'une deuxième vague parce qu'on
n'est pas du tout au niveau
dieu merci de ce qu'on a connu pendant
le printemps et mêmes vous voyez vous
citer les chiffres ça fait trois jours
d'affilée qui a une forte baisse du
solde eu d'hospitalisation d'angle tant
mieux mais donc ça veut dire qu'on n'est
pas dans la même situation
salita il faut toujours faire attention
moi je crois qu'on doit contrôler nos
frontières est né aux aéroports on doit
bien se laver les mains on doit faire
attention aux personnes fragiles c'est
une évidence mais et qu'on doit
travailler sur un traitement me trouve
qu'on a mis de côté raout les d'autres
de manière incroyable et rapide alors de
plus sûrement parce qu'il propose un
traitement pas cher et que là aussi
c'est un des sujets culturels dans livre
celui des conflits d'intérêts qui à mon
avis est un sujet extrêmement important
mais cette fois je pense qu'il faut
faire ça il faut faire attention mais on
peut on doit arrêter d'affoler la
population et je regrette qu'ils aient
pas beaucoup de partis politiques pour
pour pour le diront c'est notre rôle de
le dire et de proposer d'autre stratégie
que de détruire la france
alors si personne ne s'en indigner
véritablement est-ce que c'est pas parce
que on n'a pas beaucoup d'informations
non plus sur sur ce bien eu ce qui est
quand même assez assez opaques non ouais
effectivement il est nouveau donc
alors en même temps il ya une recherche
mondiale qui est plus forte que sur
aucun autre virus dans l'histoire et ça
se comprend
donc je pense qu'on apprend très très
vite je sais que les réanimateurs ont
fait d'immenses progrès et c'est
vraiment très heureux il sauve des vies
ils ont sauvé des vies
par rapport au début de l'épidémie je
pense que l'on apprend quand même
beaucoup mais on tâtonne forcément parce
qu il malgré tout il a moins d'un an
donc ça reste assez récent mais au-delà
de ça il ya quand même des choses justes
de bon sens voilà juge de bon sens
comment se fait-il que l'on ferme pas
nous avons pas eu nos frontières veut
véritablement qu'on fasse pas de vrais
de vrais contrôles vis-à-vis des pays
vraiment un risque aujourd'hui parce
qu'on sait que les dynamiques de
d'épidémie sont pas les mêmes dans le
monde au même moment
2 pourquoi dans le même temps on par
exemple à nice là on a on a interdit la
vente d'alcool après 20 heures
quel lien à stimuler que la situation
sanitaire l'histoire des masses que
quand vous êtes en moto ou
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce voyage
en absurdie ouais c'est voit d'un côté
il ya les mesures évidentes comprend pas
en parler des tests aussi d'autres côté
on prend des mesures absurdes qui sont
destructrices
par exemple on ferme une classe en
entier parce qu'un élève a un rhume on
peut on peut pas fermer comme ça une
classe d'un coup une école ça n'a pas de
sens et c'est grave c'est gravissime
c'est un acte lourd de fermer une classe
où une école pour l'instruction d'un
enfant d'une classe et pour le niveau
général d'éducation du pays alors
revenons à votre livre vous dites que
notre appartenance à l'union européenne
est souvent longue le mort de l'analyse
des politiques de l'opposition pourquoi
parce que moi je vais beaucoup de monde
dans l'est notamment parmi les
politiques les responsables syndicaux y
compris dans l'opposition s'indigne et à
juste titre qu on avait appauvri
l'hôpital qui ont manqué de beaucoup de
choses que la france avait été localisée
énormément d'industrie est indispensable
y compris dans cette crise par exemple
peuvent aller sauver les réactifs pour
les tests ou les cotons-tiges il manque
et c'est un ben oui mais enfin d'accord
mais c'est la responsabilité des
gouvernements mais c'est aussi parce
qu'on appartient à l'union européenne et
c'est surtout parce qu'on appartient à
l'union européenne voit la télé c'est un
concours le plus honni charles elle l'a
tout récemment sa patte bien que coville
sont allé pleurnicher sur bridgestone
qui faire qui va délocaliser en pologne
et en hongrie mais tout ça c'est lié à
notre appartenance à l'union peine à
lons et ça il n'en parle jamais si vous
voulez il déplore les conséquences des
causes qu'ils chérissent comme il est
peu bossuet c'est-à-dire qu'ils adorent
l'union européenne et puis il pleure sur
les conséquences de l'union européenne
un peu de rigueur et un peu de cohérence
maintenant et moi j'en appelle à cette
cohérence par l'offre existe
c'est-à-dire la sortie de l'union
européenne et de l'euro le plus vite
possible vous critiquez l'ailé
d'ailleurs les injonctions l'union
européenne sur la santé qui a produit en
tout cas la destruction des de l'hôpital
public on l'a vu pendant pendant le
confinement aujourd'hui vous pensez que
les leçons seront pas tiré le plan blanc
d'ailleurs qui a été déclenché dans les
hôpitaux vous pensez qu'on en est au
même point qu'au début de l'épidémie à
bien écouter tant qu'on est de toute
façon dans l'union européenne il faut
pas s'attendre à autre chose qu'une
destruction accélérée de notre service
public
vous savez là à la rentrée ils vont
encore fermé des lits à strasbourg des
lits de réanimation
1 les gens ont peut-être vont apprendre
ça ils vont croire grève et il n'y a pas
du tout que cette ville qui est concerné
en france il ya des fermetures de lits
qui sont programmés là pour la rentrée
donc si oui tant qu'on est dans cette
logique de la profitabilité de la t2a
soul et la tarification à l'activité
alors tout ça c'est lié à la vision
bruxelloise européenne du service public
qui doit devenir un service marchand a
tant qu'on continue là dedans avec des
gouvernements soumis à cette idéologie
là eh bien il faut pas s'attendre à ce
qu'on change de philosophie faut pas
s'attendre à ce que ça aille mieux
très pour moi vraiment là on appelle à
être extrêmement cohérent c'est un des
enjeux aussi de ce livre effectivement
très court florian philippot dans le
dernier chapitre de votre livre vous
appeler à la révolte à se révolter en
tout cas à l'intelligence collective
expliquez vous oui j'en si vous voulez
on voit bien selanne à rennes aussi
peine à rennes dans le livre en disant
on arrête a expliqué que pour qu'un
peuple soit docile et n'y comprennent
plus rien et qui deviennent obéissant en
quelque sorte sans trop réfléchir
il faut lui donner les injonctions
contradictoires en permanence désolé on
lui dit abbas qui est bien aujourd'hui
c'est blanc puis demain au leader
valence et noir aujourd'hui voilà bon
alors et puis le peuple ou le mans il
comprend plus rien bah c'est exactement
ce que le régime auquel on nous
contraint depuis plusieurs mois on nous
a dit les masses à rien puis c'est
indispensable et est pareil et puis et
puis voilà qui on n'y comprend plus rien
et c'est le meilleur moyen pour qu'on
devienne dociles et obéissants
ben il faut ce qu'il faut se rebeller
par rapport à ça il faut garder son
esprit critique
il faut garder un esprit de logique il
faut mettre il faut garder un esprit sur
le temps long de mettre en perspective
les paroles et les événements et et se
forcer à comprendre et à rester
intelligent c'est la première révolte
cette révolte de l'intelligence elle
entraînera les autres la révolte pour la
liberté et la révolution politique que
j'appelle c'est à dire un programme de
salut public pour la renaissance de la
france
merci beaucoup florian
pour d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce
soir sur arte france
je rappelle le titre de votre livre que
8,19 l'oligarchie est démasqué publié
sur amazon et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
dans 30 minutes reste eric
[Musique]
on doit le combattre
vous avez découvert que l'imagerie
médicale qui était le coeur de votre
métier avait une dimension artistique me
suis aperçu que c'était l'art qui
faisait avancer la science et la science
qui faisait avancer là l'image est belle
mais mais en général le mal qu'elle
révèle il est terrifiant au moment du
coc vite quand j'ai attrapé moi même
la balle a dit je me suis dit mais
pourquoi j'utilise pas ma technique de
droite et de virton life a pour mon
thorax autres et pour le virus j'ai pu
suivre son évolution comme henry ça
s'aggravait ou au contraire comment ça
c'est mc veigh quand on a découvert le
côut dont sait on sait comment ils et
comment
voilà quelle couleur il est qu'on a
découvert le mal l'e mail du mal
[Musique]
il a été baptisé tout simplement france
relance d'une ambition et d'une ampleur
historique pour arrêter les les
croyances quasi religieuse sur le fait
que l'état donne une impulsion à
l'économie ça n'est jamais arrivé
quand on fait encore une fois un plan de
relance généraliste il ya assez peu près
si vous ne satisfait personne
sur les 40 milliards attendus de
l'europe on leur en donne sens et on en
récupère 40 donc sans moins 40 ça veut
dire qu'on est en l'air de 60 là où il
fallait mettre le paquet c'est pourquoi
plus sur les petites entreprises versus
très grosse et donc vous ne fait que
creuser encore les inégalités qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui dans nos pays
là il annonce 160 mille emplois créés
mais on va en détruire combien
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous de
técou politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte là on soir vient de
grignan aujourd'hui on a une gauche
extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur des dossiers sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon interprétation
tandis que le président turc erdogan
avec l'accord tacite des états unis
pratiquer la politique du fait accompli
et du rapport de force en méditerranée
orientale et que les émirats arabes unis
accompagné par baï faisait la paix avec
israël une évolution majeure sur le plan
géopolitique s'est produite au
moyen-orient
le 23 juin le site iranien tabnak
relayée par la presse nationale a
annoncé puis publié un projet d'accord
stratégique entre l'iran et la chine
d'une durée de 25 ans alors selon armin
arefi du point
ceci a fait réagir violemment aussi bien
les opposants ultra conservateur
regroupé autour de l'ancien premier
ministre mahmoud ahmadinedjad que les
nationalistes et les libéraux vivant à
l'étranger
le 16 juillet le ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères mohammad javad
tarifs qui fait partie du gouvernement
modéré d'hassan rohani a reconnu qu'il
était en phase finale de négociation et
depuis les deux camps dans de
l'opposition accusent le gouvernement de
brader le lion persan au dragon chinois
dans ce traité qui devra être validé par
le parlement et par le conseil des
gardiens de la constitution
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avait t'il un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes
nous les avons nous pas pousser dans les
bras d'un partenaire qui ne souhaitait
pas mais qui va en profiter pour faire
de l'iran sa tête de pont au
moyen-orient
à
certes les relations entre les
etats-unis et l'iran ont toujours été
compliqué et on doit on rappeler
l'histoire pour comprendre comment nous
en sommes arrivés là
souvenez-vous en 1953 à la demande des
compagnies pétrolières américaines
la cia qui avait sur place comme
représentant on dire aujourd'hui chef de
poste
kermit roosevelt fils de l'ancien
président a renversé le premier ministre
mohammad mossadegh qui avait osé
nationalisé le pétrole
elle l'a remplacé par le shah reza
pahlavi qui a indiscutablement
moderniser le pays mais sous une manne
faire devant la montée des
mécontentements populaires
les etats-unis ont dû l'encourager en
1979 à s'exiler et a laissé la place un
gouvernement démocratique dont le
premier président fut monsieur bani sadr
il a été vite remplacé par l'ayatollah
khomeiny qui avait préparé sa prise de
pouvoir depuis la france où il est exilé
et suite à 100